so we don't have the spider-man far from
home trailer yet but we did get the
description for the trailer a couple of
days ago Tom Holland and Jake Gyllenhaal
themselves showed up in CC XP in Sao
Paulo Brazil to show the Spider Man far
from home trailer and thanks to those
who were in attendance they posted
online what they saw in the trailer so
now we know what to expect and a lot of
people were confused about the
description because at one point
spider-man
is fighting a villain and Mysterio shows
up and actually hopes spider-man defeat
this villain so a lot of people are
confused because everyone has heard that
Mysterio is supposed to be the main
villain in spider-man far from home well
he is he was only pretending to be a
hero in this scene and I'll explain that
in this video also don't forget about my
giveaway I'm giving away a life-size
Infinity Gauntlet all you have to do to
enter for your chance to win is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
one part of the trailer description that
some people have left out as that
Mysterio shows up and pretends to be a
hero he pretends to save the day and
this has been reported by many credible
people who were actually in attendance
at cc XP and saw the trailer you see
Mysterio is a villain and he's actually
a very smart and clever villain
Mysterio's real name is Quinton Beck and
Quinton beck works in the film industry
and is actually one of the most
accomplished special effect designers in
the industry Quinton decided that his
special-effects job was a dead end and
he actually sought Fame and wanted to be
an actor but as it turns out he wasn't
that good-looking one of his friends
suggested as a joke that his best way to
get famous would be to take out a
costumed hero and although it was said
as a joke Quinton realized that his
expertise with special effects and
illusions would actually make him a
pretty good villain
so Mysterio was born and became one of
spider-man's long-term enemies
Mysterio's goal was to defeat spider-man
and actually take his place as a hero he
chose spider-man because at this point
in the comics Spiderman was actually a
fairly new and weak and pretty
inexperienced hero and that's kind of
where spider-man is at right now in the
MCU if you just take into account
spider-man homecoming and Civil War
because since time-travels involved with
avengers in game we don't really know if
the events of Infinite
or or in-game are going to have happened
but that's a whole different story so if
we're going just based off of homecoming
and Civil War spider-man is still a
fairly young and inexperienced hero but
again Mysterio takes many months to
prepare
so he's studying spider-man this whole
entire time and getting everything ready
to perform his illusions and one of his
tricks is going to be pretending to be a
hero that way he can get close to
spider-man make him think that he's
actually good and fighting on his side
that way he can blindside him and easily
defeat him so this is all apart of
Mysterio's grand plan he wants to get
spider-man out of the way so he can be
this famous superhero that everybody
loves
in fact the villain that spider-man will
be fighting when Mysterio shows up to
save the day is probably an illusion
created by Mysterio in fact all of the
villains in spider-man far from home are
all probably illusions created by
Mysterio and again he's going to do this
so he can pretend to fight these
villains with spider-man to make
spider-man think that he's on his side
but of course it's just a trick and part
of a grand illusion created by Mysterio
so he can get spider-man out of the way
for good so Mysterio is not a good guy
he wants to be a hero but really he just
wants to be famous and to do that he's
going to cause a lot of destruction and
try to kill spider-man so ultimately he
wants to be a hero and be famous but
he's a villain Jake Gyllenhaal himself
said that the central point of this film
is going to be the relationship between
Peter and Mysterio so let me know what
you all think we're going to see between
Mysterio and Peter and spider-man far
from home let me know in the comments
down below and don't forget to subscribe
like the video and comment down below so
you can enter the giveaway and stay up
to date on everything relating to
spider-man far from home as always thank
you all so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]